we have another pair of committee
members for our final presentation julia
chasman is a veteran film producer with
a dozen feature credits who's been a
studio executive at Showtime Universal
and industry entertainment currently she
runs her own home design company which
designs and renovates home in the Los
Angeles area she has served on the
nickel Executive Committee for the last
six years and has been a judge since her
acceptance to the Academy in 2007
Daniel Petrie jr. is an Academy Award
nominee for his screenplay Beverly Hills
Cop he is a past president of the
Writers Guild of America West and
current president of the Writers Guild
foundation he is also a former governor
of the Academy and a longtime member of
the Academy's nickel fellowships
committee presenting the award to Walker
McKnight R Julia chasman and Daniel
Petrie Junior
[Laughter]
street rat alley as you gather from that
beautifully performed scene leads a
small band of teenage girls in their
makeshift existence in the wildly
original ramshackle hellish city of the
future where they struggle to survive as
the eldest of the girls alley is charged
with finding food shelter and keeping up
the hopes of her younger charges with no
means of support and only their rickety
skateboards to make their way these
latter day heirs to the pickpockets of
Oliver Twist must fend off daily attacks
by boys BOTS and sadistic multi limbed
futuristic creatures as they scramble
for food alley not only keeps them fed
she keeps up their spirits and serves as
a mother to the orphan girls although
she's not much older than they are okay
the bombed out city where they live was
once one of the great ones was it Paris
New York San Francisco we have to wait
until the last train pulls out at the
very end of the story to find out Walker
McKnight has created a uniquely
terrifying and fabulous post-apocalyptic
city of the future as he put it himself
in his artists statement a fun dystopia
populated by multi limbed freakish
creatures and robots but the main
characters are all beautifully realized
young women and the spirit of the script
is undeniable full of action drama humor
heart and humanism it's a unique
combination for the sci-fi genre a
native of Atlanta Georgia Walker
McKnight didn't start writing seriously
until he was thirty the time has been
well spent though as the assurance of
his years shows in his command of his
craft and a voice which is all his own
please help me welcome to the stage 2019
nickel fellow Walker McKnight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is a major phobia of mine I'm about
to have a panic attack so I think I'm
gonna read this whole page in about 15
seconds so just hold on
thank you Dan and Julia for the
incredibly kind words
thanks to Gian Don nickel for the gift
of this competition and the academy for
putting so much effort and so many
resources into it for so many years
thanks to Joan Y and Chris Carr Chi and
the nickel staff for doing the hard work
of running the fellowship thanks to
Jennifer yuh Nelson and the nickel
committee for taking time out of their
wonderful careers to help those of us
trying to learn this craft it means a
lot and thanks to the other fellows and
finalists for being such fun and
supportive partners in this process I
also have to thank the great
screenwriting teachers I've had because
they've been huge my first teachers
Jenna Millie and Michael lucker my
professor Jack Boozer from GSU and Tim
Alba who has been a big friend and
supporter these people have had to read
my worst scripts and it probably took
years off their lives to do so I'm sure
- but like great teachers somehow they
were still able to encourage me to keep
going and I think if any one of them had
said something different than that I I
might not have thanked you two rows and
a mandolin and Wes and Tyreese for that
incredible read I never expected to hear
dialogue that I've written spoken by
anyone other than the voices in my own
head and there are a lot of those you're
much better than those voices that was
incredible and thank you Geetha for for
directing that thanks for my brother
Brian for being a wonderful friend and
movie watching partner all my life but
above all above
all thanks to my parents Wanda and
Walker who fed my love of fantasy and
sci-fi from my earliest memories to
reading to me and indulging my constant
requests to bring home VHS movie rentals
with monsters in them they have
continued to encourage their child in
this crazy career path long long after
he's passed an age that any child should
need to be encouraged in a career path
so I can't thank them enough and I love
you as Julia mentioned I really didn't
start writing until age 30 I have no
idea what I was doing before that just
staring at a wall I guess with a with a
relatively late start like that comes a
pretty healthy dose of imposter syndrome
I've often felt like I was trespassing
on somebody else's career field
something that was meant really for only
people who just knew it was their
calling since childhood
or high school or college or even their
20s and so for 15 years my imposter
syndrome it's been like a constant
roommate and and lately honestly it's
really started to feel more like the
landlord really a really terrible when
banging on the door and shouting at all
hours
thanks to Nikol I now have something to
shout back and that's a really wonderful
thing to close I just want to say that
good stories are the most magical thing
in the world to me
my favorite storytellers throughout my
life have been able to conjure something
out of nothing and make me actually care
and the difficulty of accomplishing that
never ceases to blow my mind this is the
craft that I'm trying to learn and if
I'm ever able to bring even just a tiny
fraction of the thrill to somebody that
my favorite storytellers brought to me
then I'll be happy thank you
[Applause]